so let's look at the acquisitions
because the acquisitions do tell a story
twitter stock has obviously obviously
done well and
some incomplete deals it was reported
they were in talks with uh discord and
clubhouse those deals fell through
according to sources clubhouse may have
raised that four billion dollars that
might have been a preemptive funding
by andreessen horowitz and others
because they got a serious offer so i
would say maybe twitter offered them two
or three billion dollars for clubhouse
which is insane but you know such as the
industry when something breaks out and
gets escaped velocity becomes worth a
lot
we can talk about that in another
episode but the
in the venture capitals probably said
hey here's 100 million dollars you can
each take 10 20 million off the table
we'll buy some shares from the founders
to keep you in the game as an
independent company that'll probably
turn out to be a mistake if they got an
offer of three or four billion
you know usually i'd say go long but in
this situation where everybody's
building
clubhouse into slack it's being built
into linkedin it's being built into
facebook and everybody's basically
announced that they're going to build
this in as a feature i think clubhouse
is going to be
you know ultimately worth less than the
4 billion it's worth today that's just
my personal belief and i'm not saying
that to
to ride the founders or anything or
because i wasn't able to invest in it
it's just that i've never seen the
replication of a product like this this
quick
and in fact most people say the
clubhouse copied it from discord i don't
know if that's actually true but
many people have told me that that was
where the inspiration was so
but they did buy breaker which was a
podcasting app that was very interesting
breaker relied on the twitter feed uh
the twitter social graph
to tell you what your friends were
listening to in terms of podcast it was
really well done
um it wasn't my default player my
default player has the is the apple one
and the an overcast because i like the
power user features
in overcast and i like uh apple's ui
sometimes i'll use spotify but you know
i'm just kind of
been trained to use the other two
they're all seem to have parity and so
i believe what they're going to do with
this podcast player
breaker is they're going to combine the
concept of spaces with podcasting
inside of twitter and then let you pay
for it so that's probably the grand plan
you do a twitter space you record it and
then it's available for pay
on the replay so free live pay on the
replay at least that's what i would do
they bought oh wait no um back in
january of 2021 for an undisclosed
amount it's a full service creative
agency that previously worked with
twitter
and the why in the aqua hire here is to
accelerate the quality and execution of
twitter's product experience according
to the chief design officer
damply davis so who knows
what that is about it just could just be
talent this uh you know
founder wrote a funny tweet now comma
about that edit button jack so obviously
maybe he's gonna be
designing uh you know all these new
features and and creating the twitter
singularity
in the content space they bought
drivescale back in january 25th for an
undisclosed amount and that's a server
company that optimized
computing storage network fabric again
that was an aqua hire to accelerate
their app development
that happens all the time in the
industry company runs out of money
didn't get to scale
investors are you know kind of ready to
sell it the team is ready to go work
somewhere else the big one
i think one of the big ones is review
r-e-v-u-e
which is a sub-stack killer and it
allows you to do newsletter subscription
services so people who
write tweet storms now get prompted hey
check out review
and so i think this is going to be quite
material i would consider
putting you know an email newsletter on
to twitter if it made it easier to
manage because i'm constantly having
twitter users and i'm forwarding them
over to mailchimp or whatever
or a type form they acquired reshuffle
back
in march of 2021 it's an api
integration platform and they called it
a strategic aqua
and they're going to shut down reshuffle
and add those people to twitter's api
team
twitter has had a love-hate relationship
with the api they gave everybody api
access people abused it people created
mass confusion by creating twitter
clients
they redid that they shut it down they
deprecated apps
access now they want to do a 2.0 api
it's just a very hard thing to do
because when you have these apis you
create competitors
like clubhouse and substack etc
and then you may want to go into that
business and now they've siphoned off
your users
and you basically have enabled
downstream competitors which is why
zuckerberg doesn't have
apis anymore and a company we invested
in scroll
was just acquired uh in a couple weeks
ago
and uh i think it's really interesting
scroll was a subscription service that
basically allowed users to read
news and buy a subscription across many
sites and this is you know one of the
either the siren song or founders or the
holy grail
and i think this will be part of twitter
blue i think when you subscribe to
twitter blue
maybe for you know eight dollars a month
you'll get to read new stories natively
inside of twitter just like apple news
which i recently paid for
as part of my family plan so now
everybody in the family when they go to
google news
gets to read it i really love this
family plan stuff because
i might not pay for apple news otherwise
but if i'm like ah it's going to be
split between two
three four five people okay kind of
makes sense or you know icloud is
you know i get the two terabyte okay now
you know i got three kids
we're dividing the cost you know across
five people
just starts to work uh really well and i
think it's super powerful
and so you can follow try scroll on
twitter and it gives them
you know basically uh it just takes a
lot of clutter out and it makes things
really easy you take out the ads
i think this ad free experience is going
to be really neat
when you're on twitter and able to you
know just very simply
read new stories um clean fast
just like apple news maybe even
pre-loaded the news will be pre-loaded
and cached the top news and so you look
at that you know
acquisition spree from breaker all the
way down to scroll that's six
acquisitions in the first uh
five months of the year it's a pretty
acquisitive year